hi everyone
great
okay
today as promised we have the premiere
of dr ashizha our new white house kovid
response coordinator uh in the briefing
room
dr shaw will be talking about two
important pieces of work in our
we are working on with congress first
expanding access to life-saving coven 19
treatments and second our urgent need
for funding from congress he has time
just to take a very small number of
questions today but he will be come back
um after soon i'm sure so with that i
will turn it over to him uh and then
we'll proceed with another thing
good afternoon everybody
all right well it's great to be with all
of you a little um exciting and a little
scary with this crowd
um so i want to take a minute to talk
about where we are with the panda we are
i believe we are at an inflection point
one hand we know that ba2 the
sub-variant of omicron has become
dominant cases are rising across the
country
but hospitalizations are at the lowest
level of the pandemic
right
and deaths are continuing to fall
we're down to about 300 deaths a day
still too many still too high
but doing so much better than we have
throughout much of this pandemic
despite all of that progress and i think
a lot of that is driven by the fact that
we've more than 200 million americans
vaccinated more than 100 million
americans boosted we know this virus is
tricky
we know that the risk of potential
surges even of a potential new variant
remains out there
the good news is we are at a point where
we have a lot more capabilities a lot
more tools to protect the american
people
testing
vaccines therapeutics
these are the sort of the pillars of how
we manage the rest of this pandemic
and that's why what i want to do is
spend some time talking to you about
those tools about our capabilities what
we're doing as an administration and
what we need from congress to continue
to protect the american people so first
i want to talk about pax levitt uh the
the therapy that has become
is becoming increasingly available to
the american people uh for those of you
who have not followed this very closely
pax levitt became authorized by the fda
in late december at that point there was
just a very limited supply of these
pills
the clinical data suggests that it has
an enormously beneficial impact reduces
hospitalizations by more than 90 percent
and
is very very effective at preventing
severe disease over the last few months
the administration has worked very hard
with pfizer
to increase the supply of paxlevid and
acquire
more and more doses for the american
people
and now our job is to make sure that
these doses are getting out there and
they're getting into
uh into the hands of patients who would
benefit from them so what are we doing
and i want to talk about four major
things
um the first is we are opening up uh the
number of sites that can order directly
from the federal government uh supplies
the packs of it until until this recent
change
the way pharmacies got packs of it
either you were a test retreat site or
you got it from your state
but now we're opening up a federal
federal
pharmacy channel and what that means is
pharmacies can order directly from the
federal government
currently there are about 20 000 sites
in the united states that carry packs of
it we expect with this change that we
will very quickly get to 30 000 and
within the next couple of weeks i expect
us to get to about 40 000 sites
pax of it will be widely available
everywhere in america
that's going to help a lot
the second
is the president announced the test to
treat effort that that we have launched
right now there are about 2 200 test
retreat sites across the country
and we are going to make a series of
efforts to expand the number of pesa
tree sites
including
new federal initiatives that will allow
for us to build on other federal testing
sites to allow for uh for those to also
have a treatment component so if you
test positive you can go and get uh
treated with packs of it of course if
you are eligible uh and deemed so by by
a provider um third is we really are
doubling down on our communication and
education efforts with physicians and
other prescribers uh in the beginning
when the when when pax of it first
became available
the word on the street was these things
are now widely available you should
restrict it to the highest risk patients
too many physicians still have that
mindset
and what we need to do is to help
american physicians and nurse
practitioners and others who can
prescribe understand that we now have
plenty available and anybody who is
eligible anybody who's high risk should
be getting pax lavid
obviously base as long as they meet the
clinical criteria
and so that education campaign is going
to be really important and then last but
certainly not least is we're ramping up
our public awareness campaign so that
patients also understand that if they
test positive
they should consider going to a test to
treat site or reach out to their
physician but to get assessed for
whether paxlevid would be useful for
them
those are all really critical steps that
i think are going to make an enormous
difference in getting more packs of it
out to the community to getting it out
to patients and with a very simple goal
right which is we want to lower the
severity of the disease that people get
if they get infected and we want to
lower hospitalizations we want to lower
deaths
paxlavid is a really important step in
our ability to fight this pandemic
treatments like these vaccines that we
have developed
these are the key essential tools that
we're going to need to get through the
rest of this pandemic
and that's the second part of the
conversation i want to have with all of
you
because all of this
requires funding from congress
so far congress has not stepped up to
provide the funds that are needed for
our most urgent needs now i know they
were off on a two-week recess they are
back
i'm looking forward to working with
congress we all are
to get
the funding needs of the american people
met on this uh on the issue of kovid and
cova treatments let me give you a couple
of concrete examples of what will happen
if we do not get the funding we need
you may have heard if you've been
tracking this
that fda working with
modern and pfizer
looking at what the next generation of
vaccines may look like
and it is possible that we may get a
whole new generation of vaccines in the
fall or winter
that may be more effective and more
durable
none of those are going to be available
to the american people if we don't get
more funding
we are tracking new treatments that are
coming online
that are
as effective maybe even more effective
with fewer side effects
those treatments will not be available
to americans because other countries are
stepping up and making purchases for
those treatments
while we await funding from congress
the bottom line
is that none of us can predict with any
certainty where exactly this pandemic is
going what the virus is going to do next
all we can do is prepare
and that's what we need congress to do
is to help us prepare and be ready for
whatever eventuality comes let me make
one last point that i want to i think is
incredibly important
and that is that there are some people
in in this country who sometimes think
that we can take a domestic only
approach to a global pandemic
that's not a thing you can't do that if
we're gonna fight a global pandemic we
have to have a global approach
that means we need funding to ensure
that we're getting shots in arms around
the world the president and in his
leadership has enabled us to now have
plenty of vaccines for the world
but vaccines don't save lives right
vaccinations do we have got to finish
the job we've got to get the resources
we need to get shots in arms so we can
actually vaccinate the world and help
bring this pandemic to a close so those
are um those are the essential things
that are in front of us
this will require a partnership between
the administration and congress i am
confident that congress will deliver for
the american people and i look forward
to uh working with them on that thank
you
uh every time a high profile person like
the vice president catches kova for
attention on the infection uh for
americans following that news what
lessons should they draw
uh from that experience if somebody is
protected as her has caught coven yeah
good question um so i think if you take
a step back and look at uh the vice
president she is boosted actually twice
boosted right
um
we have a very very contagious variant
out there it is going to be hard to
ensure that no one gets coveted in
america that's not even a policy goal
the goal of our policies should be
obviously minimize infections whenever
possible
but to make sure people don't get
seriously ill
the best ways of doing that are making
sure people are vaccinated and boosted
as the vice president is and making sure
we have plenty of therapeutics so
um you know so that that is available as
well
and that to me is the key lesson here is
she receiving any therapeutics since
we're on the topic of therapeutics you
know that's a conversation that she's
having with her physician i'm not her
physician i'm not privy to those
conversations so i don't know the answer
to that thank you dr john welcome to the
briefing by the way um
to your to your point that so many
americans can and will get this this
report that just came out today that 60
of americans have had it appears have
had coveted
the president is getting ready to ramp
up his travel schedule the vice
president just caught it she's twice
boosted
should americans be prepared for a time
when president biden gets this is it
just a matter of time that the president
could get covered
i wouldn't say it's just a matter of
time but of course it is possible that
the president like any other american
could get cove the bottom line
is he is vaccinated and boosted he is
very well protected he's got very good
protocols around him to protect him from
getting infected but there is no hundred
percent anything
and i think the key focus has got to be
we've got to continue protecting the
president uh that's what the protocols
does around him are designed to do
yeah let me just let me leave it at that
tam yeah um
part of the congressional funding is to
potentially deal with the uninsured fund
that is run out of money
what does the uninsured fund not having
any money in it mean for pax logan or if
if someone who's uninsured gets covered
right now what does that mean for them
yeah so first of all pax love it itself
will be free right because
they have to see a doctor but they have
to see someone who can actually
prescribe it for them and
this is one of the absolutely critical
things in a pandemic is that people need
to be able to access healthcare turns
out it's also critical not in a pandemic
right um but but particularly in
epidemic with an infectious it's really
important that people be able to access
healthcare services
get the care they need
it's good for them it's good for people
around them and so making sure uninsured
people have access
is absolutely critical so right now what
does that look like if someone gets
coveted and they're uninsured um are
they able to get treatment are they able
to get um
tests or
uh does cbs just eat the cost how does
that work i think right now because we
don't have the funding there's a little
bit of patchwork of what is happening
there are obviously places that serve
uninsured people community health
centers
others people can get care there are
still people are still going to
cvs and other places that still are
offering uh those services but that's
not a sustainable solution right so
right now we're in this kind of middle
ground where people are still getting
care but over time if congress continues
to not fund these urgent priorities it's
going to get harder and harder for
people to access care
christmas you'll be the last one too i
apologize i'll be back soon go ahead
thank you dr john thank you so much for
being here just a couple of questions
one can you tell us
was president biden tested today and has
he tested negative do we know the last
time he tested negatives i don't know
i'm not involved in the president's
testing protocol so i i just don't know
the answer to the question
yesterday
okay thank you um on pax a little bit i
just want to be crystal clear because
you're
trying to expand access to it but you
still say if people meet the medical
requirements
does that mean that pax loaded should
only be taken by people of a certain
agent who are immunocompromised
or that it should be taken by anyone who
has symptoms no so so neither the fda
has laid out a very clear set of
criteria for who should get packs of it
and very basically it's anybody who's at
high risk of developing complications
and the fda points to a cdc assessment
it's a it's a long list i can read it
all to you but of course age is
important presence of chronic diseases
but the bottom line is that and what i
i'm recommending to family and friends
is if you get coveted you should see a
provider and make that assessment with
your provider
a lot more people are eligible and ben
would benefit than i think people think
and just very quickly can you help us to
understand this moment that we are in
because on the one hand cases are going
up particularly on the east coast as you
have said hospitalization and deaths are
going down but is the country in the
midst of a search
what i would say is you know we are
going to see cases go up and go down
during this pandemic as we as we head
into the weeks months and years ahead
the key things that we need to be
following are our health care systems
getting stressed
are people ending up in the hospital
with severe illness obviously are people
dying at high rates those are the my
mind the most important metrics and
right now while infection numbers are
rising and of course we all want to see
infection numbers coming down
the good news is because of the
extraordinary work of this
administration we've got americans much
better protected
and that means
uh that we're not seeing a huge bump in
hospitalizations the debts are still
declining obviously we want to continue
tracking those metrics
you're invited any time all right thank
you everybody
thank you
okay a couple items at the top um today
we announced this morning that during
second chance month president biden made
a number of announcements focused on
second chances and re-entry which as
leaders on both sides of the aisle
recognize will help prevent and reduce
crime and strengthen our communities the
president announced 75 sentence
commutations and three full pardons all
of these individuals were convicted of
non-violent drug offenses and many have
been successfully serving their time on
home confinement he also announced more
than 20 major actions from a dozen
agencies to expand second chance
opportunities this includes a first of
its kind partnership between the
department of justice and the department
of labor to invest 145
million dollars in job training and
intensive re-entry in federal prisons it
also includes steps that will make more
incarcerated students eligible for pell
grants make it easier for those who are
incarcerated to enroll in medicare and
help formerly incarcerated veterans get
their benefits restored as we speak
susan rice dana remus and cedric
richmond are holding a virtual round
table with six formerly incarcerated
individuals to discuss the president's
first clemency announcement the new
reentry policies and programs we
announced today uh today's announcement
mark import marks important progress and
we will continue to review the president
will continue to review clemency
petitions and deliver reforms that
advance equal justice and public safety
also wanted to note that today uh
secretary austin miassin hosted a
meeting of the ukraine defense
consultative group with ministers of
defense and chiefs of defense from more
than 40 countries at ramstein air air
base in germany the goal is to bring
together countries from around the world
for a series of meetings on the latest
ukraine defense needs to help ukraine
win the fight against russia's unjust
invasion and to help ukraine's defenses
for tomorrow's challenges as secretary
austin said it was an important and
constructive day agenda topics
included near-time near-term priorities
and longer-term planning the latest
battlefield assessments of the renewed
russian offensive establishing a
framework for prioritizing requirements
and logistics for resupply and
energizing the defense industrial base
to continue to the steady flow of
security assistance more than 30
countries have now stepped up to meet
our ukraine's urgent needs and have
committed more than five billion dollars
of equipment including 3.7 billion from
the united states to support
ukraine's defenses we also wanted to
welcome
an important announcement by our german
allies today to send ukraine some 50
cheetah anti-aircraft systems we would
also highlight the british government's
announcement yesterday that it will
provide ukraine with additional
anti-aircraft capabilities and canada's
announcement that it will send ukraine
armored vehicles i believe that's it why
don't we jump around to people who
didn't get questions initially go ahead
thanks jen quick question on dr joe
talking about cases going up and the vp
testing positive um
can you talk a little bit about whether
the administration and society as a
whole perhaps have moved away a bit too
quickly from mitigation efforts such as
masking and is the administration
perhaps thinking about strengthening any
of those measures especially the ones
that were losing well those decisions
and those recommendations are made by
the cdc and our public health officials
so
i don't have anything to preview for you
those are decisions that they make and
we obviously abide by that from here i'd
remind you that their recommendations
include
are based on what zone of the country
you live in uh right whether it is a
green zone yellow zone uh or a zone that
has a higher uh rate and they continue
to recommend masking on transportation
on you know that we and we abide by that
from here as well so i'm i don't have
any any changes on that to preview but
as as as dr john noted um our focus and
as we noted when we rolled out our
100-page plan continues to be on
tracking reducing hospitalizations and
deaths and we're certainly aware that a
very with a very transmissible variant
that there we expected there could be a
case increase as we've seen over the
last few weeks with ba2 even in the
regions that are witnessing a surge i
mean there is there are no discussions
that perhaps you can talk about about
you know what these latest sort of um
surgeons uh cases could potentially well
but masking requirements uh change
depending on what uh the numbers look
like in your community right okay uh and
and a quick one on um the eu reuters is
reporting that the eu plans to declare
that it is entering a new um supposed
emergency phase for kovit
given sort of the uptick in cases in the
u.s i'm wondering if you can talk a
little bit about that timing i mean is
that unusual uh or do you think it is
the right time for the for countries
around the world to be headed uh towards
that goal and if the us is perhaps
considering announcing something similar
uh going forward i don't you mean an end
of the emergency um i don't have
anything to preview again those
recommendations are made by our public
health and medical experts so uh we rely
on them for their guidance on that and
can i ask one on ukraine sure um so
just earlier today the announcement from
germany on a new package for heavier
weapons uh that obviously comes uh you
know as russia has said that such
assistance would lead to a nuclear war
uh and it sort of seemed like the us was
rushing off russia's uh recent nuclear
threat and i'm wondering if the
administration to what extent is it
really taking this latest threat
seriously
well i think you heard some of our
national security officials make clear
there's no winning a nuclear war and
obviously our objective continues to be
to call and are reducing the rhetoric on
taking the rhetoric on that front down
and i think there have been some
officials who have abided by that but i
would note that the announcement by
germany is in line with announcements
we've seen by a number of european
countries in providing assistance they
have never before provided which is part
of the significance here so this is an
unprecedented change to provide lethal
aid to another country and that's the
significance here from germany but i'd
also note that norway uh provided uh
mistral anti-air missiles
that
a number of countries have provided
types of assistance that they have never
done in the past and that really speaks
to this the unity of uh nato of european
countries and confronting uh what we see
as uh of course a horrific war in
ukraine launched by the russians go
ahead um is it possible that there might
be any updates to protocols covet
protocols within the white house in
light of vice president harris testing
positive for clothing
i would not expect that no
so there are no discussions and you
don't expect that i think it's important
to remember that we have stringent
protocols here that go over and above
cdc recommendations even as it relates
to how long you stay at home
if you test positive
so individuals who test positive for for
here and i can speak to this two times
over um
there you go um
you uh don't return to work until you
have uh you have received a negative
test if that is before 10 days you are
still going to be masking that is beyond
what cdc protocols are there's a regular
testing cadence obviously the vice
president was tested this morning
because of that regular testing cadence
and for the rest of us anyone who's
going to be around the president to
travel with him to see him in the oval
office is tested that day and even if
you're not going to see him you're on a
regular testing cadence around here we
also take the step to socially distance
in meetings as frequently as we can
and also a number of us have chosen to
wear masks in meetings as well just as
an additional a step in protocol so
those have been in place uh prior to
today and we will continue to abide by
those moving forward just on a different
topic um senator manchin
told reporters this morning that there
is not a build back better revival
he said that social spending programs he
believes should go through regular order
not through the reconciliation process i
wondered if you could explain just from
the white house's perspective how you
all are thinking about reconciliation
versus regular order in terms of wanting
to get done some of the president's top
legislative priorities well you've heard
the president say many times that he
believes that a lot of the objectives he
has should be achievable
through bipartisan work together
it's not democrats to you know democrats
shouldn't be able to own efforts to
reduce prescription drug costs or the
ability to negotiate the price of
prescription drugs nor should we be the
ones completely owning on our own
efforts to lower the cost of child care
health care those aren't democratic
ideals those should be those are those
are proposals that are broadly supported
by many americans across the country um
so we i we know that that senator
manchin has of course talked about his
efforts to pursue a bipartisan package
or bipartisan plan as it relates to
energy
costs and we're not going to prejudge
that effort but we're going to continue
to engage with a broad range of
democrats including of course senator
manchin about how to get the president's
agenda done is there anything you can
tell us about the president's schedule
today there wasn't anything uh publicly
announced is he in touch with uh members
of congress particularly since they're
coming back this week i expect he will
have a range of conversations and
engagements with members of congress he
also has a range of internal
meetings policy meetings planning
meetings um there's nothing more i can
uh preview on that from here but if uh
if there's more i can tell you after the
briefing i'm happy to do that um go
ahead we've got jen i'll start with
something else senator manchin said sure
you're just talking about him he said
today we need an immigration policy and
title 42 should not be done away with
until we get an immigration policy or
until the cdc basically says we no
longer have a health crisis
what does it say about
the communication with
members of the president's own party
that senator manchin believes that title
42 is an immigration tool
well i can't speak to that necessarily i
can tell you that what it is and isn't
it is not an immigration tool it is a
health authority and one the cdc our
health experts of course uh do have
authority to make a decision about and
they've made the decision that the
conditions no longer exist to keep title
42 in place we do agree with him
absolutely there should be an
immigration policy and there should be
immigration reforms and they're long
overdue and we'd love to work with him
and any other members on moving that
forward does it concern you that he's
saying that title 42 should not be done
away with until there is an immigration
policy well that's just not how it works
um
obviously title 42 is
the authority was given to the cdc by
congress they made a decision if
congress wants to decide make any
decisions about the next steps for title
42 they can work together on that but
that is an authority or a decision that
have to but would have to lay in the
body that he works in and then i'm going
to follow up on what doctor john said
about us to treat site yeah
what is the administration doing to
expand those sites including converting
some testing sites to have
a treatment component what are the
challenges to that and do you have any
time frame for when you expect to ramp
up those facilities yeah it's a really
good question we shall probably have to
talk to dr ja and others from the health
care team about it
and next time he'll take more questions
i promise
you're right there are some challenges
just like any aspect of applying uh
covid policy or cove
treatment policies or covet
efforts to fight covet policies in that
uh we have to educate a large swatch of
the public including healthcare
providers about how this works or how it
would work uh there's continued efforts
to do that but i'm happy to check with
them on expansion plans or how that
might work one more quick one on
vaccines for children under five yeah
the group protect their futures just one
of many groups that are urging the fda
to consider medera's application
for an eua before june which is when
pfizer will also submit theirs
what is your response to these groups
who
are concerned that appears concerned
that it appears the administration is
doing pfizer a favor by waiting to
consider both moderna and pfizer at the
same time when modernist data is already
ready for review by the end of this week
i'd really point you to the fda for
their decision-making process but i
would tell you that of course as a
parent of a child under five i'm eager
to have vaccines approved and available
and i want to make sure they go through
the proper protocols and process but i
would point you to the fda and uh
yeah
there are eighteen thousand petitions
pending for plumbing yeah does the
president plan to increase his pace and
consideration as he talked about
possibly doing and also is there
uh a consideration of a permanent
permanent clemency review process that
would kind of institutionalize this
process going forward well first let me
it's important to note that the
president has issued more sentence
commutations at this early point in his
presidency than any of the la his last
five predecessors at the same point in
their first terms so we are far ahead of
anyone any of the last five presidents
that is because this is a priority to
the president
and as i noted uh when i at the top of
this briefing he feels this is
second chances are important and he
believes is absolutely a right step in
our justice system he is he's going to
continue to review uh clemency
petitions and that is going to be an
ongoing process that is of course run
through our council's office so it
doesn't stop here it will be ongoing and
there will be more in the future
thank you jen um on title ratio we've
heard you guys say that this is a public
health order it's not an immigration
order it's the cdc's decision
uh but yesterday members of the
congressional hispanic caucus who met
with the president um relayed some of
what he expressed in that meeting um and
one of them said that the president told
the group
that he was looking forward to lifting
title 42 describing it as an excuse to
keep people out of the country an
anti-immigrant
is the president
really wanting title 42 to go away
because it was a trump era policy
well the president has never felt that
title 42 was
a an effective immigration policy and he
talked about that during the campaign
but the authority has always rested in
the cdc to make that determination and
he left the cdc to make that
determination unlike his predecessor
about a range of decisions so the
president has never
never
made a secret of the fact that he thinks
immigration reform is necessary and that
title 42 was never a replacement for
comprehensive immigration reform that
would put in place smarter security that
would ensure there was
an asylum processing system that worked
and that is something he would be eager
to work with anyone on to get done so if
this conditions warranted it would the
white house want to see the cdc reimpose
title 42
in the instance that the cases are up
and the metrics that they use to measure
that warrant that decision well the cdc
again has the authority to make a
determination about what the health
conditions uh warrant
so we will leave at the dem to make any
decisions or recommendations with the
vice president um being out obviously
she's broken a lot of ties um for votes
and then we have senators i believe uh
wyden and murphy also out is there any
concern about ability to
get confirmations through this week
with her absence
well i would say there are also some
democrats who have announced that they
have also tested positive for covid
you may be referring to the federal
reserve nominees or others
that is something that members and
leaders will work through in congress we
we are confident we have the votes uh to
get them confirmed we're eager to have
them in place um but of course we need
all people all members there to do that
and i had one follow-up on dr john
something that he said earlier
we've talked about the administration
surging resources to the border
including
resources to vaccinate migrants
and the last time i asked about this i
believe your answer was something along
the lines of we have enough funding and
supply to take care of
the 23 sites that dhs is going to be
running to get migrants vaccinated and
also take care of uninsured americans
but it sounded in his answer like that
might not be the case anymore so are we
in a place now where
there might be a choice where people
would have to choose or the
administration have to choose between
supplying resources to migrants coming
across the border versus taking care of
uninsured americans i'm happy to check
on those resources jackie i would say
that
our broad concern about covid funding
is based on a couple of issues that he
talked about one of them is making sure
that we are ahead of the world on being
able to order ahead primarily a lot of
different treatments that uh will help
ensure that we have the best vaccines
the best boosters
enough supply once once
individuals under 50 are eligible and
certainly we want to keep all of our
programs uh running across the country
but
i just have one more on the hunter biden
reporting that we've seen come out
does the president still maintain that
he never spoke with his son about his
business dealings and given this
reporting on eric schwerin does he
also say that he has never spoken to his
son's business partners about his son's
business dealings
uh he maintains uh his same statements
that he's made in the past i would say i
know you're referring to
waves records that were released more
than 10 years ago i really don't have
more detail or information on them i'd
note that there was a gap when waves
records were not released but i don't
have more information about visits from
more than 10 years ago go ahead oh let
me go around to people who haven't got
go ahead oh thanks um two questions on
the war on ukraine yeah first one on
food aid yeah does the administration
have any idea of how much money you'll
need yet
for for global food aid given the the
shortfalls due to the war on ukraine
sure so um
when we first say that we are not
expecting a food shortage here at home
uh but we are acting to bolster food
security around the globe both
unilaterally and in conjunction with
allies and partners
one of the steps we're taking is we're
really conducting extensive diplomacy to
encourage all countries to refrain from
export restrictions and excessive
stockpiling obviously buying up or or
not exporting uh goods or products they
would normally do because it can
exacerbate supply chain uh chain
challenges uh and price inflation and
and we want to consider how to expand
production of key uh areas where we
could see that happening oil seeds and
associated commodities we're also
working through multilateral channels
including the g7
to
to provide
a range of funding to the global
agriculture and food security
program a 1.7 billion dollar
multilateral financing mechanism is is
part of what we've done there that has
helped the world's poorest countries
increase investments in agriculture and
food security as we're anticipating
global shortages in some regions of the
world and through feed the future and
new nutrition commitments we're also
committing over 11 billion dollars over
the next five years to address food
security threats and nutrition across
the globe in addition to the over four
billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance funding so we've taken a
number of steps funding mechanisms uh do
you know multilateral financing
mechanisms also contributing um and and
trying to use through diplomatic
channels uh you know efforts to to
prevent stockpiling and and and
decreasing of exports because we
anticipate it could be an issue and
we're already seeing that in some parts
of the world okay so no idea what the
global overall total would be for how
much food age
i don't think we have a prediction of
that at this point so what we're trying
to do is we're trying to get ahead of
what we anticipate being a shortage or
an impact in some parts of the world and
working through
multilateral mechanisms to help address
that even as we don't foresee it being a
food shortage issue here natural gas
russia says it's going to cut off poland
starting tomorrow which is a pretty big
escalation by russia is the
administration concerned that gazprom
might cut off other european nations
from to get natural gas supplies and is
the us going to do anything to help
poland make up for sure
let me check and see if there's anything
specific to poland what i can tell you
and we've talked about the little bits
in a little bit in here before is that
for the last several months and even
prior to the invasion we have been
working to increase natural gas supply
and options to european countries that
have been reliant on
russia for natural gas supply in
anticipation of the possibility of this
happening or a decrease in what they're
providing so some of that has been
asking some countries in asia who have
excess
supply to provide that to europe we've
done that in some cases and it's been an
ongoing effort but i can see if there's
anything specific for poland given this
recent announcement go ahead
thank you um two questions on the
pardons um there were pardons and
communications there were three pardons
two of them were for non-violent drug
offenses can you talk at all about sort
of what it was about those two cases
that
stuck out to the president given that
there are a lot of people who
applied for pardons that have similar
circumstances and and didn't receive a
partner today is there anything about
those two that are emblematic of
anything that is on his sure well i
think many of you reported on these
cases and the compelling nature of their
personal stories um but i would note
that his focus at this point in time was
on individuals who had less than four
years to serve
a number of them a good percentage of
them and i can find the exact number in
here are also already under home
confinement um currently
and this is again just the first step
and he will continue to review
clemency
requests and petitions um over the
course of his presidency and certainly
in the coming months
in addition there's a large backlog of
people who've applied for pardons and
commutations and given that was there
any denials in this first wave is he
denying anybody a pardon or commutation
it's a good question i'm happy to check
with our council's office and see or if
it was just this was the first round
that was granted through the process
going through
um two questions jen um first following
up on dr zhang he said that um he talked
about global funding yeah it's pandemic
yeah republicans have said that they
want that money offset so has the
administration does the administration
intend to propose
ways to offset that five billion dollars
or do you think that's a lost cause and
second um the president has a number of
crowded events coming up on his calendar
a couple of funerals the white house
correspondents dinner and in light of
the vice president's diagnosis can you
talk about the calculations
that the president is making and
thinking about
whether to attend these kinds of events
and also whether he has any special
obligation as president to keep
himself sure
well in the first question cheryl we're
not quite there yet i mean we have
requested 22.5 in the past and obviously
that is where our emergency request will
be moving forward for the short-term
needs that we have
this has been passed past coveted
funding as you well know has been passed
through emergency authorities where it
hasn't been offset and we certainly
think that's reasonable but we're at
such the early stage of this process
having not even sent it up to the hill
yet we're going to have to have all of
those conversations about how to move it
forward on the second piece what i will
tell you is that
we make risk assessments here just like
every american does and as it relates to
of course keeping the president safe and
all of us safe now naturally he has
access to the best health care in the
world he
consults closely with his doctor we take
a range of steps i i noted in response
to mj's question earlier that go beyond
even most workplaces in the country in
terms of required testing for those who
who will be around him social distancing
obviously he has his own regular testing
cadence but we do make assessments and
and he makes assessments about
when he feels it's important for him to
attend or participate in an event and
you mentioned two of them obviously this
weekend
he'll be attending the white house
correspondents dinner it's an
opportunity to honor the work of all of
you and many of your colleagues
and to
and to talk about the importance of
journalism in the world uh that's an
event he's attended many times in the
past and he made a decision through
consultations that it was an event he
could attend and wanted to attend again
uh and obviously uh former vice
president mondale someone he had an
important personal relationship with he
wanted to attend his memorial service
obviously these discussions are always
done through our scheduling team the
covid team to make sure we're taking
every step possible but just like many
americans
he makes risk assessments and i would
say the last piece which you didn't ask
about but you know people asked about in
here as well as he's been traveling the
country more recently um you know he was
traveling three days last week and
we and of course uh coordination with
the president made a decision that was
vitally important to him to his
presidency to the american people
and certainly that's one of the reasons
we want to be very clear that it is
possible he could test positive for
kovid that
just like any american even though he's
double boosted that is possible um and
uh you know we we will of course uh be
very transparent about that if that were
to take place
yes i do go ahead yeah yeah and then
i'll try to go to the back go ahead
thanks multiple
outlets cbs and washington post have
reported today that uh in yesterday's
meetings with meeting with the
congressional hispanic cospicus the
president biden signaled
that he was prepared to use executive
authority to cancel
student debt in the coming months can
you confirm that this was something
relayed
to them by the president and why
what exactly is the president considered
doing when it comes to to student aid
debt sure well let me use this
opportunity to reiterate that nobody has
paid a sing a penny in student loan
federal student loans since the
president took office and what we've
said from here is that and what he
reiterated is that
he will make a decision uh before
there's an end to that pause right now
it's been extended uh through august and
we have talked about how we are looking
at and he is looking at other executive
authority uh options he has uh to bring
relief to
people who have student loans um so
that's what he conveyed during the
meeting regarding using executive action
though i mean is that something a step
now that the president is seriously
looking at well we've talked about that
in the past um so he's continuing to
look at it
going back to vice president harris's
positive test for covet is the white
house uh trying to determine exactly uh
where and when she would have been
exposed to covet as the assumption that
it was during her trip
to california last week and is that
white house
uh in the vice president's office doing
any effort to contract trace in order to
maybe notify people
during that lengthy trip to who she
might have uh ran into just like um and
for anyone who tests positive around
here we do contact tracing uh so that
people are aware if they should take
additional measures or precautions
whether it's masking or getting
additional pcr tests and we're certainly
doing that uh in light of the vice
president's positive test as well go
ahead thanks john i wanted to ask if the
white house had any reaction to that
court case that uh put the temporary
block on title 42 being repealed
and then i have a follow-up question
about vice president paris sure well
things sometimes happen when i'm out
here but when i before i came out here
they had uh only done kind of the verbal
briefing as of last night so i'm not
sure if there's has there been a new
development or that okay so what i will
tell you is that department of justice
will
need to review um kind of any
any rulings before commenting and that
was verbal there'll be something more
formal as our as our expectation
and they would discuss any next legal
steps or interpretation of the ruling so
we'll leave that to them and we'll see
if more comes out today
president harris do you know the last
time she was tested prior to this
morning and is there any uh therapeutics
that she's taking
so she's on a regular testing protocol
just like the president i can certainly
check and see um that information um and
then as dr zhao referenced she would
consult with her doctor on any
treatments
go ahead nadia thank you on foreign
policy a national security adviser jake
sullivan supposed to meet with this
israeli canterbur park tomorrow um
the israelis have made it publicly known
that this disagreement with the white
house with iran and going back to the
negotiation can you update us first of
all why he's coming here what's on the
agenda and i have another question sure
um well they uh consult regularly i
would say as you know the president uh
had a fruitful conversation with israeli
prime minister bennett just a couple of
days ago
and so this is a follow-up to that
conversation and they'll discuss a range
of regional and global security uh
issues um and part of that you know the
president when he spoke with prime
minister bennett uh they also talked
about a range of global and regional
issues and prime minister bennett
extended an invitation for him to visit
israel which he accepted and will do we
don't have a date yet to announce they
also talked about
the iran nuclear deal negotiations which
we uh we keep the israelis uh briefed
regularly on so uh certainly that could
be a part of this conversation as well
also secretary king this morning
testified at the uh senate foreign
relations committee he said that
breakout time for iran is weeks away he
blamed the previous administration from
withdrawing from the deal
does this worry the white house that
we're talking about two weeks that iran
could actually develop a nuclear weapon
yes
it definitely worries us um i would say
that if we go back you know under the um
under the iran nuclear deal iran's
nuclear program was tightly constrained
and monitored by international
inspectors and since the trump
administration seized u.s participation
in the deal iran has rapidly accelerated
its nuclear program and reduced
cooperation with international
inspectors uh in non-performance of iran
uh nuclear deal commitments so as you
noted of what secretary blanken said
during his testimony this morning was
that their breakout period is down from
about a year which is what we knew it
was during the deal to just a few weeks
or less
and certainly that is a direct impact of
pulling out of the nuclear deal making
us less safe giving us less visibility
and it's one of the reasons we uh
pursued a diplomatic path again when the
president uh took office
okay april last one okay label last one
legend two questions sure really fast
tomorrow's a new day
go ahead april
hello this is a prom sorry um jen the
two questions
on haiti uh what are the conversations
can you shed light on the conversations
about the hate uh haitian
immigration issue
as title 42 is set to end
next month and also
as the vice president has tested
positive for posing and it is in the
realm of possibility as the president is
traveling
if he gets coveted in this moment what
is the line of succession if both of
them are very ill with hope at this
point
well technically the speaker of the
house is the third in line so there you
go no i'm just confirming that for you
um it is true as we've noted many times
it is possible the president could test
positive we will be very transparent
with you if that were to happen he has
access to the best health care in the uh
in the world and we
believe because of all of the
precautions and steps we have taken that
he would be able to continue his duties
as the vice president is as well as vice
president so i don't have any prediction
of that at this point in time in terms
of your first question on haiti tell me
a little bit more about what you mean
the way i understand
that there has been a conversation or
various conversations to include
at the u.n here about how do you handle
the
haitian migrant issue when haitians are
being sent back and then you're bringing
other refugees in and i'm hearing that
there are conversations around the
administration about how to handle once
title 42 is
i would have to dig into this a little
bit deeper i mean as you know there is
tps right um that has been granted uh
for a period of time so that is a
something that uh haitians who have been
here at a certain but from a certain
point in time have access to um beyond
that
our focus though is of course on uh
continuing to be the largest provider of
aid and assistance to haiti um ensuring
we can take steps there to lead in the
world encouraging other countries in the
world to take steps as well um beyond
that maybe we can talk after the
briefing and i can find out a little bit
more about jameen i will go to the back
tomorrow first thing thank you so much
everyone american engineers gas prices
especially low income american legit